hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast CTS stem Pro HSC
expansion medium for cell and gene
therapies presented by Abigail Harris
Becker scientists Thermo Fisher
Scientific I'm Christie Joel of lab rats
and I will be your moderator for today's
event this presentation is brought to
you by laborat and sponsored by thermo
Fisher Scientific for more information
on our sponsor please visit thermo
Fisher com
I would like to remind everyone that
today's event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
in the ask a question box and click send
we will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit
I would now like to introduce today's
speaker abigail harris becker scientist
Thermo Fisher Scientific Abigail
completed her master's degree in
biomedical sciences at Penn State
College of Medicine in Hershey
Pennsylvania where her graduate research
focused on the role of genetic and
epigenetic alterations of acute myeloid
leukemia abigail joined Thermo Fisher
Scientific in the cell biology business
based in Frederick Maryland in 2016 as a
R&D scientist abigail is part of a team
focused on research and development of
cell therapy grade products that support
translational and clinical research
workflow for a complete biography on
abigail harris becker please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
Abigale you may now begin your
presentation
you
Thank You Christy hello I'm Abigail
Harris Becker and I work at Thermo
Fisher Scientific in the R&D department
that focuses on cell and gene therapies
therapy's take life at the enablement
stage but there is a need to build in
sustainability to develop these
therapies into commercial products that
can meet patient demand thermo Fisher
has the global footprint and a history
of providing high quality technologies
and regulatory support that clinicians
need as they move to sustainable
manufacturing of these new therapies
our CTF products are developed to help
ease the transition from the bench to
the clinic in addition to GMP
manufacturing and quality systems our
CTS products provide traceability and
regulatory support currently our
products are already in fda approved
therapies and more than 100 clinical
trials
one of our most recent CTS products
focuses on Hamada poetic stem cells or
HSCs HSCs are self renewing multipotent
progenitor cells that are found in the
bone marrow and peripheral blood and are
defined by cd34 surface marker
expression HSCs
are of particular interest as potential
treatments for blood disorders
immunological diseases and cancer HSCs
can be genetically modified for example
by transfection or transduction as shown
here on the right and then transplanted
into the patient to provide long-term
protection from disease the modified
HSCs must successfully and graft into
the patient's bone marrow in order for
HSCs to engraft and repopulate the bone
marrow they must retain their full
functionality proliferation and
differentiation capacity one of the
major limitations to utilizing HSCs and
cell therapy is the limits on cell
numbers that can be harvested from a
single bone marrow or cord blood donor
expanding HSCs ex vivo would increase
the number of patients that could be
treated with a single harvest from
either bone marrow or cord blood
however ex vivo expansion of harvested
HSCs results in rapid differentiation
and progressive loss of cd34 expression
current media systems support the cd34
positive progenitors that provide
short-term bone marrow reconstitution
long-term engraftment requires the true
Hamada poet exten cells which are
thought to be cd34 positive see d90
positive in the cd45 or a negative
subset
however this subpopulation of HSCs is
currently not effectively expanded in
commercially available media systems
to address this challenge we use an
iterative design of experiments approach
to develop CTS stem Pro HSC expansion
medium with the goal of maintaining and
expanding that rare cd34 positive CD 90
positive cd45 are a negative population
the data on this slide focuses on cd34
positive cells from mobilised peripheral
blood from three donors the cells were
expanded in CGS stem Pro HSC expansion
medium supplemented with stem cell
factor flit three ligand thrombopoietin
interleukin three and interleukin 6
after seven days we evaluated the total
nucleated cells or TNC and cell
viability and we determined the
phenotype by flow cytometry using the
attune NXT flow cytometry
we show that stem Pro HSC expansion
medium provides about a 100 fold
expansion and all three donors shown
here and that more than 60% of the
expanded cells are cd34 positive note
that while the competitor media expands
both the total nucleated cells and cd34
positive cells only stem Pro HSC medium
expands both the short-term cd34
positive progenitors and it provides far
superior expansion of the long term cd34
positive CD 90 positive cd45 are a
negative cell populations
transplantation of ex-vivo cultured cd34
positive cells is the gold standard to
assess whether or not the expanded cells
maintain their functionality here cd34
positive cells from mobilized peripheral
blood were expanded for seven days in
stem Pro HSC expansion medium
supplemented with the same five growth
factors the expanded cells were then
transplanted into immunodeficient and RG
mice after six months we monitored human
cd45 positive cell populations in both
the bone marrow and spleen obviously you
wouldn't expect any human cells in mice
so the presence of any human cd45
positive cells or Kaymer ISM indicates
that these human cells have persisted at
six months post transplantation this is
indicative that the cells did
successfully and graft into the bone
marrow when these cells that were
cultured in stem Pro HSC expansion
medium were transplanted into the NRG
mice we see that human cd45 positive
cells are tenfold higher in bone marrow
and twofold higher and spleen compared
to the non expanded cells in addition
the cells exhibited multi lineage and
graffman including cd34 positive HSCs c
d 33 positive myeloid cells and c d+ c d
19 positive b-cells
in addition to maintaining the cd34
positive stem cell population stem Pro
HSC expansion medium supports
megakaryocytes and erythrocyte
progenitor cells
megakaryocytes by the progenitors that
differentiate into platelets while
erythroid progenitors differentiate into
red blood cells here 50:34 positive
cells from mobilized peripheral blood
were expanded for seven days in stem Pro
HSC expansion medium supplemented with
the same five growth factors at the end
of the seven days we evaluated total
nucleated cells and cell viability in
addition we looked at the immuno
phenotype
the percent expression of cd34 CD 41 and
CD 71 using the attune and XP flow
cytometry here you see a more than 2000
fold increase of both the cd34 positive
CD forty one positive megakaryocytes
progenitor population as well as the
cd34 positive TD seventy one positive
erythroid progenitor population
here we show cd34 positive cells
isolated from the three most common
tissue sources three mobilized
peripheral blood donors - cord blood
donors and - bone marrow donors the
cells were expanded in stem Pro HSC
expansion medium shown in blue or one of
two supplier media again while all three
media expand the total number of cells
and maintain cd34 positive expression as
shown in the top and middle charts stem
Pro HSC expansion medium expands both
the cd34 positive progenitor cells and
provides superior expansion of the long
term cd34 positive CD 90 positive cd45
are a negative population
I'll move on to methods for genetically
modifying HSCs for cell therapies here
mobilised peripheral blood cd34 positive
cells were thawed and pre stimulated in
stem Pro HSC expansion medium containing
the same five growth factors for 48
hours cells were then transduced for
another 48 hours with CTS LV max
generated GFP virus at the various mo
eye is indicated transduction efficiency
was evaluated by flow cytometry at 48 72
and 120 hours post transduction
on the left the top row of dot plot
shows the percent of cells that are
double positive for GFP and cd34 at the
mo I indicated the bottom row of dot
plot shows the cells that are triple
positive for GFP cd34
and C D 90 moving to the right the
middle two charts show the percentage of
cells that Express both GFP and cd34 as
well as the mean fluorescence intensity
of the GFP expression in addition all
time points and all mo eyes showed high
viability
that cd34 positive cells cultured in CTS
temporal HSC expansion medium can be
transduced with Lenti viral vectors with
a 5-2 38% transduction efficiency when
using the cts LV Mac system
Chris Burke assigned gene-editing allows
genetic material to be added removed or
altered at particular locations in the
genome here mobilize peripheral blood
cd34 positive cells were cultured in
stem Pro HSC expansion medium prior to
neon electroporation for the transection
of true cut cast line protein guide RNA
and gfp donor DNA
cd34 positive cells cultured in stem Pro
HSC medium showed approximately 20%
transfection efficiency as a point of
reference t-cell transfection efficiency
with this system is approximately 10%
here we're showing the percentage of gfp
positive cells
cd34 positive cells and CD 90 positive
cells as determined using the attune and
xt flow cytometry the Center chart shows
that cd34 positive CD 90 positive cells
are present in the gfp positive
population demonstrating that these
long-term HSCs are permissible to gene
editing using this system
the far-right panel shows the in vitro
colony-forming assay of gfp positive
cells here we're showing that
this resulted in granulocyte and
macrophage colony is designated as white
colonies here as well as erythroid or
red colonies this indicates that the
functional capacity of the cells has
been maintained following
electroporation
in summary CTS stem Pro HSC expansion
medium was developed for cell therapy
applications with regulatory compliance
in mind it is a serum free Zeno free
cGMP manufactured media system that is
supported by a drug master file and
regulatory support file to assist our
customers in global regulatory filings
and approvals the media system expands
cd34 positive cells from the most
commonly used tissue sources and
enriches for the rare cd34 positive CD
90 positive CD 45 re- subpopulation it
maintains HSC functionality and
differentiation capacity and enables the
expansion of cd34 positive cd4 T one
positive megakaryocytes progenitors and
cd34 positive CD 71 positive erythroid
progenitors in addition it facilitates
engraftment in an animal transplant
model and is compatible with gene
editing and transduction workflows
additional data and information can be
found at thermo Fisher comm forward
slash stem Pro HSC thank you for your
attention and now I'd like to open it up
for questions
you
Thank You Abigail for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of our webinar also joining
us today for our live Q&A we have
Jacqueline region and germ of cell and
gene therapy a PJ region of Thermo
Fisher Scientific now to our audience if
you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now just click on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen and we will answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for okay let's get started now
let's see let's go with this question
and I just let's have you answer this
one do I have to use the growth factors
that Abigail has recommended
sure I'll take this one so for optimal
performance
we recommend SPF with three ligands tpo
IL c and i on 6 so that's the set of
cytokines that we recommend using a
designer's experiment approach we
evaluate the impact of these growth
factors individually and in combination
we found the best performance when the 5
are used together the concentrations and
Kappa lot numbers for these growth
factors can be found in our product
manual online but should you wish to add
your own growth factors and use your own
combination you could do so
Thank You Jacqueline
Abigail let's come over to you for this
question why is this cd34 positive CD 90
positive phenotype significant sure in
2017 there was a publication from the
Fred hutch Institute where they showed
that the cd34 positive CD 90 positive
population is highly enriched for stem
cells I'm at this subpopulation was
responsible for a multi lineage
engraftment in a non-human primate
transplantation model that paper was
published in the Journal of science
translational medicine in 2017
thank you have a gale now the data
showed seven days of HSE culture will I
get more cells if I culture for longer
than seven days sure I'll answer that
one as well
so while greater numbers of cells can be
achieved with longer culture periods you
have to remember that the percentage of
cd34 positive cells is going to continue
to decline over time and culture so we
evaluated culture periods that range
from 3 to 14 days and we found that 7
days is really optimal optimal as it
produces significant expansion of HSCs
and maintains a high percentage of cd34
positive cells so for example at 4 days
we saw about a 25 fold increase in cd34
positive cells and greater than 95% of
those cells 4 cd 34 positive whereas
after 7 days we saw greater than 100
fold increase and we were still showing
grow up more than 65% of those cells or
cd34 positives so we recommend 7 days
however obviously if people want to
experiment and see what might work
better for their needs you know makes
sense to do a time core study if you'd
like to evaluate that further great
Thank You Abigail
now Jacqueline let's come over to you
for this one what is the format of the
media
the media is salt as the kid containing
a 50 times supplement which is a 10 mil
file and a basal media 500 mil basal
media that must be combined and
supplemented with cytokines or growth
factors before you the supplement is
stored at negative 20 degrees Celsius
and can be thought in four degrees
overnight or at room temperature for a
few hours supplements should not be
sought at 37 degrees the best the basal
media is shipped at ambient temperature
and stored at 4 degrees for more
information you can look through the FAQ
on the product webpage
now we're speaking of media what type of
GNP RCTs subculture media manufactured
according to I can take this question
CGS products are manufactured excites
that our ISO 13485 certified they're
complying with us FDA quality system
regulation 21 CFR 820 they are
registered with the SBA well the
products themselves are generally not
medical devices the manufacturing sites
do manufacture medical devices and the
quality systems are aligned to medical
device manufacturing spend it
thank you now Abigail let's come over to
you and what system were that were the
cells expanded bioreactor flasks so we
evaluated from like multi-well plates I
think down to 48 well plates up to
larger tea flasks we haven't completed
any work yet in either like bio reactors
or G Rex but at the moment scale up
through two large tea flasks we're
showing equivalent expansion regardless
of the 2d culture system and we do hope
to generate some application data for
larger scale culture formats
Thank You Abigail do you have any
suggestions regarding most efficient
methods of cell culturing suspension
adherent R&D phase bioreactor so again
at the moment well we can really only
recommend what I've looked into which is
the sort of smaller scale 2d culture in
terms of a you know bioreactor scale-up
I would encourage anyone to reach out to
us and perhaps we could help come up
with some initial testing to for people
to establish protocols but at the moment
I don't have any recommendations for
larger scale up
thank you and Jacqueline can we come to
you for this question how do i request a
DM app or regulatory support file for
this product you could go to a
demolition website and request a letter
of authorization you would need to
complete an online form outlining the
product that you are using the clinical
application reference number title
agency division and your company contact
details we will process your request and
contact you for further information is
required the most requests can be
completed within one week Thank You
Jacqueline and looks like we'll wrap
with this final question in your DL wave
for the growth factors did you also
evaluate different concentrations for
each factor or can you share what
concentration that you used yes so we
did I did a full do a screen on the five
growth factors we recommended so I
looked at at least three concentrations
for each as well as so I did this
analysis or the data analysis as well as
the experimental planning using the jump
software so that allowed me to not only
recommend an ideal concentration for
each growth factor but it also confirmed
that all five growth factors really do
provide a benefit in terms of cell
expansion we recommend the
concentrations that we recommend are
listed on the product page or the
product insert and again as Jacqueline
mentioned earlier if anyone would like
to evaluate additional growth factors
obviously they're welcome to do so but
we did really screen these growth
factors and put a good bit of work into
establishing what we think are the best
concentrations across a variety of
tissue sources as well as individual
donors
Thank You Abigail and thank you
Jacqueline both for this interesting Q&A
session do either of you have any final
comments for our audience
the cime can go coach sorry go ahead
overhead hello I was going to say that
if you've got a any technical questions
wise we could write into our text apart
email box or go online to our optimal
Fisher Scientific Support website
and I was going to suggest if anyone has
any would like additional information or
would like to review any of the
application data that we've shown here
you can go to thermo Fisher comm forward
slash stem Pro HSC there's a lot of
great information as well as FA cues
thank you both for your time today and
for your interesting presentation before
we go I do want to thank our audience
for joining us today and for their
questions those questions that we were
not able to answer today or those that
are submitted during our on-demand
period they will be addressed by our
speaker via the email address that you
provided at the time of registration I'd
like to once again thank abigail harris
becker and jacqueline for their time
today and we would also like to thank
elaborate and our sponsors Thermo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on demand and lab routes will
alert you via email when it is available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event that's
all for now and we hope to see you again
soon have a great day